moi je remarque quand même
philippe bouvard qu depuis que vous êtes
ici vous n'avez fait aucune citation
et pourtant vous êtes le roi de la
situation 1 vous avez ça en commun avec
philippe sollers et et jean d'ormesson
on va faire une interview qui a dix qui
a dit le plus beau moment de l'amour
c'est quand on monte l'escalier paluches
non non et tristan bernard
tristan dames 1 je ne vérifiait quand
ils viennent les jeunes maintenant ch
pas le fait encore tient à ce qui est
dit quand j'écoute trop wagner j'ai
envie d'envahir apple
woody allen m'a rien dit on ne prête
qu'aux riches on a raison les pauvres en
bourse difficilement comment ça pourrait
ça pourrait être le fond ça l'est non
jules renard non tristan bernard est oui
qui est dit au paradis on était assis à
la droite de dieu c'est normal c'est la
place du mort c'est la place du mort qui
est lundi tirent l'ipp impôt sur les
chihuahuas à car le joueur suit la
divulgation nationale a fait son oeuvre
exactement qui a dit je suis un
agitateur ans provocateur un vrai animal
chez madame je suis gens n'agissent
tateurs un provocateur mais s'est
présenté des sels d'or sur des oeufs
sinon c'est un peu moins bien en ce
moment
vous savez qui c'est les enfants ce qui
s'y dit la culture moderne jean pascal
de l'astarac par une oreille à certains
grands auteurs accès dégaine chypre à ce
bébé là en venir là on doit bien
ration plus tomber en main et
jean-pascal de la star et séverac
tristan bernard bon il n'a pas été dans
le loft
non ça qui est dit paris paris on peut
qu ils sont plusieurs d'entre elles sont
au nombre de boules est passé le reste
des français on à wimereux les
supporters de noël
qui a dit quel connard c'est philippe
bouvard c'est un ami à vous non
ce soir
bah quoi ces deux
tirage de 150 milles 1 un tirage de 500
mille exemples oh là là et vous allez
voir avec plein de nouvelles rubriques
avec de la publicité comme s'il en
pleuvait enfin un c'est la résurrection
on vous le souhaite bonne chance enfin
j'ai dû laisser filer